[Music]
in parkour seniors news oh [ __ ] - bye -
bye what is that sound Japanese also by
sounds like something important
historical figure we should know about
what we don't cuz we run culture he's
the one that brought like irrigation to
like someone civilized people or
something yeah that's pretty good that
sounds good I'll take it to seniors
escape their nursing home to attend the
walls largest heavy metal festival that
is hardcore that's time he's heavy metal
that old now that senior citizens wrap
his neck oh no it's gonna be the music
for senior citizens yeah sure there will
be current rap obviously always but then
they'll be the senior citizen right [ __ ]
yeah I know like that's the only rap the
new rap sucks ass that's like a few
years away if not know in like 37 or 35
- like their 40s I feel like it's like
60 days away like it feels like it's
really close
well Snoop Dogg's a grandpa ready what's
like the official age of senior 65
really nothing beyond to me they used to
be like 55 bro I'm 55 when can you get
the senior discount is that it yeah they
used to be in the 50s
yeah Denny's is like 55 so that I think
it's 55 remember when you were like 20
and anybody older than 25 was old as
[ __ ] I think that that's true for any
age like I remember being 15 years old
I'm thinking that people who are 18 your
oldest [ __ ] yeah
I thought they were cool though I was
like I can't wait to be 18 but then when
I was 20 on that I won't ever want to be
25 that's old and disgusting I always
wanted to be old but since I'm around so
many old [ __ ] now I can tell the
difference so that's why I'm like 65 is
not that old
have you seen like 82 well that's you
don't have you seen 105 that's but back
in a day like regardless if you were 50
or [ __ ] 80 to me that was just one
category
bold as [ __ ] when everybody's always
like you know 70s the new [ __ ] 60 or
177 when are we just gonna admit people
are old as [ __ ] I think when you one you
have certain threshold you old as [ __ ]
now and there is no going back it's 25
you're not pretty consistently
especially like with girls right
like all that he is like oh I'm 35 but
that's the new 20 like I never asked you
that's about to keep coping you [ __ ]
cold as you said that and you swung your
validate you know I'm saying it's just
coke dude yeah I keep hearing actually
over and over it's like nobody needed
that tail in comment no stupid people
we're talking about you know any stupid
people do you always has the examples of
like the stupidest people ever you and
Julie because it makes good you know
what the difference is between I
actually go out like you guys never go
out that's true you guys never go out
that point a lot of friends too huh
so we got these two bunnies and you're
talking to us this 30 is the new 20 yeah
they're growing their own friends that's
true yeah exactly
you're raising your little best friend
we're supposed to put that out in the
public charge that's the sign these two
seniors they escape their nursing home
and the police found them at this
hardcore metal festival it's called
Wacken open air and this takes place in
Germany by the way I am only part of the
cops Novacek there to the Burger King
and before the pregame show
they hired scooby-doo when were they
[ __ ] off they were like yeah we'll go
look at the enemy manifest I know like
oh my god this is the four-day fest and
bands like Judas Priest dancing Dying
Fetus and Cannibal Corpse Danzig Danzig
thank you I only know Judas Priest yeah
but do you can you name a Judas Priest
song this is my problem with Judas
Priest
I can't name a single what I hurt if I
heard I'll be like oh yeah probably me
too but anyway about 70,000 people
attend and this is holy [ __ ] they look
like [ __ ] corn fields themselves M&T
thousands that parking or is that human
beings that's a lot of horny old people
do I like how orderly it is to is that
German engineering I know everybody
everyone in perfect squares
this is human hands I don't know that is
amazing and we're all talking [ __ ] and
it's super popular everything is a lot
of poop a lot yeah I always think of
that like the bathroom situation can I
take a shower for days can we bring up
an example of what heavy metal sounds
like I feel like I should know what
heavy metal sounds like they have the
fastest drums in any music I've ever
heard no I only know like 10 years old
heavy metal cuz that's when I got into
it but that's like Avenged Sevenfold
it's not really like those people mmm
it's slower you haven't sevenfold his
way fast it's way faster
oh you sold out do this hold up I like
those guys nothing about the genre means
like the live performance yeah any more
culture David no all I know is hip-hop
you go out and hang out with friends you
got no glue I do but I know hip-hop it
are big war and my friends are no no
guar no what is that
Lars the [ __ ] funniest heavy metal
I've ever seen it's like it's like
pretty cool death metal but basically
they are doesn't metalcore death metal
well they they they dress up and like
[ __ ] crazy outfits and they have like
gigantic [ __ ] dicks on their costume
and they run around the stage and
they're I don't know how they keep their
dicks up because they're their dicks are
[ __ ] like this big LED and they
always stay up somehow so I think they
have must attached with strings of a
cold shoulder so the dicks are always
[ __ ] walking around no matter who is
president they always have a big paper
mache head of that person and then they
[ __ ] cut the head off in the middle
of show and like blood like goes out in
the audience and they always jerk the
dicks and come on the audience and the
audience like [ __ ] loves it that's
insane
it's great I want to get paid to come on
the audience right and the audience
loves it that's cool
that's what's cool but it's not real
common if it was real I think yeah
that's [ __ ] wild its gimmicky come on
maybe it's like something delicious like
custard
always look on the bright side it's not
like about you yeah one of the live
performances
this is slow compared to modern data
what are they Marvis [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah I also need a guy who's like you
know where they were kids Pig karaoke
Michael and they just sound like they're
screaming right I love that [ __ ] you
know what's [ __ ] great so we have a
power lift engine right and a lot of
power lifters like love metal yeah and I
can't even understand what the [ __ ]
they're saying but they can mouth the
lyrics no they bump it okay focus I keep
my sheep and then it'll sacrifice the
capo and they're like [ __ ] I might have
a [ __ ] even know the lyrics either
you're probably pulling up the lyrics
online and then they memorize it while
they're listening to the song cuz I
would want to sing to it too really I
don't listen to it but I know what it
sounds like they always play that bar
belt and the lyrics are great a lot of
it's like biblical it's always biblical
love the wild they always use words like
forsaken and all kind of crazy [ __ ]
forsaken bout [ __ ] turn water into
wine I know what it sounds like as you
hear it on TV or some baby yeah I never
in my life have I had it in a library
downloaded or listened to it on my free
time yeah yeah that's like the the thing
is a very special occasion I feel like
you gotta be done particularly okay some
people do it all the time though I know
I want to come over you mind kickback
and they just I used to know a guy who
listened to metal but oh he only did it
so that he could front that he listens
metal that's a poser yeah he had like
[ __ ] monkeys or whatever it is the in
his tape there and then that plated and
he was like who's I don't know how she
got in here sick food my mom put it in
here whatever I'm like dude you're
busted baby
but you gotta keep that image up you
know are they like cool oh [ __ ] yeah
well he was one of the metal kids of our
high school here's like black trench
coats and shared and Mike yeah but all
that was supposed to make you feel
tougher if you have like black glasses
circle he did not have glasses
I always recognition metal and goth
confused
the metal goth enlike just all that
whole genre what sucks
I even thought like people that were
into hair bands and like kiss and stuff
was a part of that crowd which is not
yet at all different yeah and then punks
different to you punk is the way
different yeah so let's puck then punk
is like the same five chords being
played it's all power chords it's like
kids with down jackets and my 50 patches
that are put on what's just like
non-secular Christian music and Nicki I
would say mainstream punk would probably
be like green day before the emo album
like the Dookie won't blink man 22 or
big fish that everyone was like you're
not punking where you pop now [ __ ] you
and all this punk pop I'm taking off
this button yeah offspring penny wahoo
no there Pennywise is punk Austria's
like alternative offsprings already just
pop version hope that every what about
yellow card yeah you new found glory
Mike I don't know I can't what is that I
don't know anything about that [ __ ] I
know uglies do you guys have a k-rock
version of whatever in Sacramento
already listening Sacramento that you
guys listen to I just never listen to
that [ __ ] oh i strictly only listen to
hip-hop and R&B that was the only thing
and occasionally like whatever my [ __ ]
choir teacher me listen didn't have like
a bad music station I think sucks I
don't care I think punk sucks
I think heavy metal as much as I love
the idea of it and like all the imagery
and the dragons and the Forsaken mess of
it yeah really sucks like it actually
sucks at if you ever got into
skateboarding you woulda really liked
punk I like
got like all that [ __ ] I listen to
everything you like Paul I listen to
everything though yeah Nikki likes punk
- I can't get it I don't know if I could
just be walking down the street you have
to be a part of that life man yeah nada
and the [ __ ] punk music yeah but I
wasn't like punk punk like the type of
punk that skateboarders isn't - it's
very different from the dudes that like
we're straight-up
that was Pennywise punk yes Pennywise
lag wagon that kind of [ __ ] you got what
about the jean jacket in the [ __ ]
mohawk it means a different Punk yeah
yeah that's different pop but I'm
thinking the kids who suck at
skateboarding who go to Jamba Juice
that's the people he just said yeah
emotions no it's not what did you say
was that bad yellow Clark yeah that's
those guys Oh like the Hot Topic because
at the mall you know like bands like
yellow card or you know that type of
music I heard that [ __ ] a lot in the
packs on soundtracks yeah so like those
people would have clicked in my head the
other day there's a lot of like evil
rappers that are hot hot right now right
yeah about the same subjects a yellow
card did I can't be perfect nobody loves
me but it's in a rap form now and that's
like the voice of the youth right now we
were in high school those beds were
popular because that's how kids felt you
know nobody [ __ ] likes me yeah I'm a
loser blah blah that rap is the same
[ __ ] yeah cuz kids always gonna feel
like that
exactly so what the [ __ ] I don't
understand why kids like these guys so
much is that us because it speaks to
them right now and that those little
yellow card bands was that of our age at
the time yeah it's better than our
generation though right on our enemies
that's our version of no one loves me
yeah yeah [ __ ] the police
yeah
whoo she was a big like alternative
chick she's like I'm all T I'm super
into this space like I'm punk rock and
then I found out that she listened to my
chemical romance and I was like you need
to take our own house like you gotta
take the all this [ __ ] down alternative
rock thirty Seconds to Mars is like
alternative it wasn't that an era in the
early 2000s in late 90s there's nothing
like that anymore that well that was
when they were all considered
alternative rock right yeah the great
genre music that one uh
Franz Ferdinand modest mouse no--don't
older than that no the cure there was
only one type of music to me and it is
but La Batre is the single greatest type
of music although like look at this
photograph [ __ ] like just [ __ ] high
speed you know what you guys don't like
about Creed as women his face no you
like to listen to music and you look
it's you wettreich music gets you wet
yeah for once music also gets dudes wet
hello you can you guys can't stand it
you can't [ __ ] it in I've never got me a
wet Crede makes me cream makes me
Christian yeah okay well
[Music]